Massachusetts judge ordered the release
of the redacted information in a lawsuit
against the maker of the painkiller
oxycontin the Massachusetts Attorney
General said many of the redactions
pertain to how Purdue Pharma and members
of the Sackler family who owned the drug
maker allegedly helped to engineer an
opioid epidemic the lawsuit targets
eight members of the Sackler family and
other company executives Purdue rejects
the accusations tonita copal has been
following this story for about two years
now Tony good morning good morning for
two years and this is potentially a big
break in that story good morning to all
of you late last night the Massachusetts
Attorney General's Office told us the
judge's ruling adds to what may be the
most complete allegations to date
against the company and the family
behind it it means nearly 200 previously
redacted sections of the lawsuit could
soon be made public that includes how
much money members of the Sackler family
made in Massachusetts and the alleged
illegal tactics they use to make it the
lawsuit is already the first to name
some of Purdue farmers owners that is
the Sackler family claiming eight of
them participated in a deadly and
illegal scheme now at a recent statement
Purdue criticized the claims in the suit
calling it a rush to vilify a single
manufacturer whose medicines represent
less than 2% of opioid pain
prescriptions the state has until midday
Friday to release an unredacted version
of the complaint but the fight is not
over Perdue tells CBS eight intends to
seek a stay to prevent the redactions
from going public so this meanwhile 130
people on average per day continue to
die of opioid overdoses and so you think
the impact of this is what more states
get in on this well what you're seeing
in this lawsuit could eventually become
public in a federal lawsuit a massive
one which has the potential to bankrupt
Purdue and many other of opioid
manufacturers real test case there yeah
and the information in that bridge was
redacted it could be quite explosive
indeed thanks Tony